Josh I'm it's so Bittersweet to talk to
you today can I just say the chaotic
energy that you gave this season I
absolutely loved it it was so
entertaining as a Survivor fan to watch
so now that you you know the episode has
aired everything has been seen how are
you feeling today
feeling good you know obviously
obviously it's in game I've been
watching from the beginning and
um this is seeing yourself getting
snuffed by Jeff is like oh my God I
played that game but uh you know it's a
dream to win so it was it was it was sad
but I was so happy in the long run well
that's good I like the positive outlook
on everything that's always important
especially going on a show like this and
seeing how everything plays out and
having to wait all the time for for
everyone to see it play out
um so I quickly want to talk about your
time on Tikka you know you switch tribes
after going on this journey and the
dynamic between you jam jam and Carolyn
seemed very interesting
what was it like you know you spend all
day together what was it like being with
just them that whole time
it was craziness you know like there's
so much to do when you're at camp like
getting wood trying to find food and
still trying to um maintain and put on
the space to play the game yeah and
coming in it is halfway through you know
I always already felt always felt that I
was only out so I was always trying to
do something to come get me a little bit
further but I kind of knew that they
were talking more so and it just was
chaotic for me so trying to get ground
on this was just really hard
so going to then when everyone arrived
on the beach you know you're seeing
familiar faces from Soca you're seeing
people you've never met before is it
overwhelming getting to I guess it was
technically before the merge but kind of
emerge and all these kinds of things
is it overwhelming or are you
immediately strategizing okay what's my
next move I was immediately strategizing
we call it murgatory just because like
in between
um so I was excited to get to the beach
and see Soca because of course I thought
it was so strong that was not the case
um so I was excited to share what news I
had and just try to work with different
people because it wasn't really working
with Carolyn and jam and I wish it would
have
um and I just wish I would have left
some things on Tika Beach and not
brought that whole drama I wish we would
have stuck together going forward so
immediately I was strategizing once we
got there I want to talk to as many
people as possible
um to see what was what get some
information going
so then did your strategy change after
the purple team lost the challenge or
how did you go you know half the tribe
is a way at a merge Feast talking you
don't know what they're saying and then
you have these other five people with
you how did the dynamic change it felt
and looked very chaotic people throwing
different people's names out you were
campaigning for Jam Jam people through
Kane's name out there what was the
energy like when you guys got back
uh so what US six got back first it was
like hey our say doesn't really matter
but I still wanted to campaign
um as best I could to get the heat off
my back because you have a group of 12
to 14 people on the same Beach but now
it's gotten reduced to six so I'm kind
of used to being in a group of three so
I was like okay well you know they know
our history let's just I'm throwing
Jam's name out there that'll just be an
easy vote it's only three Tikka and me
thinking stuff Soca strong when I talk
to Heidi I was like well I can bring
Lauren into and we can get them out so
that was the initial response but at the
end of the day we didn't really make the
decision because we were
on The Chopping Block so when they got
back immediately I want to talk to
Franny because I thought Franny and I
took us strong and she was saying Kane
and that made sense to me because we can
start to get out wrought to remain Soca
strong and I wanted to get Carolyn back
on my side and show her that I'm not a
part of this meat Brigade so we can get
Kane out he's one of those strong men
and then maybe get her back on my side
yeah and speaking of Carolyn obviously
you didn't see until last night but she
was like talking about everyone was you
know talking about your idol is it real
is it not and she was like guys like
this isn't real but for some reason no
one seemed to question or like inquire
about this like after that information
had been given to people was that ever
brought up to you by anyone oh Carolyn
said this it just seemed like it was
kind of like okay just gonna brush that
off
uh so I figured when we split when
Carolyn went over there she was going to
say something about my fake Idol I
didn't know how I was going to be
intercepted or you know who would trust
that
um but when we came back I started
talking to Matt and um he asked me
straight up he's like is you is your
idol real and is it the one from the
cage like is mine fake and I was like no
I don't have one I was trying to work
with him like I don't have an idol but
with me going over there and knowing
that Carolyn's gonna say that I wanted
to create chaos with that maybe get the
heat off of my back I'm like okay no one
knows if I have I don't I do if I don't
and then those who I tell I do maybe
they can give me some more information
about other tribes and what the dynamic
is and what's going on do you know what
I mean like so I was trying to like do
the best I could with what I had
that's all you can do right like at that
point I don't know if you were in like
fight or flight mode like did you feel
like you were gonna be the one going
I felt that I felt like I was always on
the shopping blog I just felt like I
always had like a Target on my back and
so my whole game plan going to the show
was just try to make myself look as
small as possible
um just being a black gay man you know
you're always looked at as either
aggressive
um or Shady so it's like
um being a surgeon I'm always used to
being control being a leader and I don't
want to do that because that'll put a
big Target on my back as aggressive so I
just wanted to try to lie about who I
was my condition and stay quiet and
still be that
um strength for the tribe so they would
keep me around and I would be considered
less of a threat but even so it still
was
why do you think people looked at you as
a threat like everyone kept saying oh
Josh is a big threat Josh is a big
threat like what do you think looking
back at it now
made you that big threat
that's that's a great question I'm not
sure I'm not sure I knew I honestly
immediately going in I just knew I was
going to be a threat just because my
physical prowess because I do have a
scar on my stomach I do have a tattoo on
my back so I'm considered mysterious and
so I was like okay well I'll use that to
my advantage and just win these comps
win these challenges
um and just stay quiet but I was too
quiet I was considered cagey and that
put a Target on my back so it's like I
don't think anything I do would have
done I would still have that Target it's
just I didn't maneuver and like go about
it the right way
okay fair well hopefully you get some
more insight later on you can be like
guys like what actually is the tea what
happened
um I quickly want to talk about you know
you mentioned a few times today about
Soca strong was there anyone that you
really feel betrayed your trust or that
you thought you had a closer tie to on
that tribe Matt yes Matt so I um was
talking to Matt immediately and we had a
really good relationship like I thought
we did and then once Manny became Manny
began Franny and Matt uh then I just
felt like
for any put a Target on my back from
from that point on so that Matt a little
bit of betrayed because we were talking
a lot when we got to murgatory Beach and
I thought we were just more stronger
than that because we decided at soccer
that we're going to stay Soca strong so
I was coming with that mentality back
but it backfired
that's I I was a Survivor fan it's so
interesting to hear these Dynamics and
all these things because there's only so
much you could pack in an hour-long TV
show so
thank you for being so candid and honest
because it's the inside us Survivor fans
need
um and lastly I just want to ask you
looking back at your time on the show
what's your biggest takeaway or the
thing you that maybe you learned about
yourself well on the beach in Fiji I
cannot tell a lie to save my life I am
such a bad liar and that I'm I am an
emotional person I I think I think with
my emotions and and I saw that with Jam
Jam in eyes relationship when I felt
betrayed by him
um I took that too far I didn't stay in
the game I thought with my emotions
because I wanted it so bad and when it
didn't come out it just I think I
reacted on that and I threw him under
the bus instead so I wish I would have
have you know
um not been so emotional but I've
learned I'm emotional and that's not a
bad thing but playing Survivor you kind
of put that away you know yeah no
absolutely well thank you so much for
chatting with me today it was a pleasure
watching you like I said chaotic energy
and also you know a great moment for the
black community lgbtq community in the
black and lgbtq community so thank you
so much for sharing your story it was a
pleasure watching you on the show and
I'm so sad to see you gone but I'm
looking forward to the rest of the
season I hope you are too I'm excited to
see how it plays out but it was lovely
chatting with you today so nice to meet
you thank you Alyssa